what I care about is living in a country
where you know decent people can live
happy lives actually I don't want to put
10 million men out of work and the
cascading effect from that will wreck
your country hey hey and welcome to the
sunday special I am super excited to be
joined by Tucker Carlson and we're gonna
jump into his brand new book ship of
fools which is already a massive
bestseller on the New York Times charts
and on charts that are more reputable
than the New York Times charge we'll get
into all of that in just a second but
first we have to talk about your
imminent death so you're gonna die at
some point here and that's why you need
life insurance life insurance isn't the
most enjoyable thing to think about most
people don't like thinking about dying
but having life insurance is a really
good feeling because you know that if
you do platz your family won't have to
start a GoFundMe to stay afloat policy
genius is the easy way to get life
insurance online in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
do disability insurance auto insurance
home insurance if you care about it they
can cover it so if you've been avoiding
getting life insurance because it's
tough or confusing give policy genius to
try just go to policy genius com get
your quotes apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing right now on your phone
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again you
need life insurance okay I know you
don't think you do I know you think
you're never gonna die especially if
you're a young listener to this show I
promise you one day you'll be on your
deathbed you'll be like God it's too
late to have gone to policy genius
that's why you should have done it
before you idiot go to policy genius
right now and take care of it it is the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance ok so let's start off with
this a lot of people don't know your
actual background like where you came
from because you know folks sort of
exists in the immediate ecosystem so
what is it where did you come from
where'd you grow up how did you become
Tucker Carlson the biggest host on I
mean I filled a job that was open I mean
a chance plays a massive role in life
which is part of the thesis of my book
and it's unacknowledged but I grew up
here actually and I'm from Southern
California originally I live right here
in Los Angeles very close to where we
are right now I'm actually with the
first grade in this town and then I
moved to La Jolla
and then I was went to high school and
college on the East Coast and kind of
stayed in Washington where my family had
moved to work for the regular
ministration and I've been there ever
since I mean I've had a series of jobs
mostly in print a magazines newspaper
and then website and then worked at CNN
MSNBC PBS and for ABC and Fox so I've
just kind of been always in the world
that I occupy now with varying degrees
of success based partly on the amount of
effort I was exerting in the job I was
in and also based on luck and things you
can't control so so what sort of shape
where you are politically right now
because if I look at your political
career you were much more aggressive on
foreign policy in the early 2000s for
example now you're that now you're much
more isolationist very on foreign policy
well how did you move can you kind of
chart your political movement oh yeah I
mean I have always tried to be much more
than right I've tried to be
evidence-based I don't especially as I
age I believe less in theories or
constructs and I believe more in results
and then I also believe in honesty and
so if you think that the policy that
you're proposing will you know reach a
certain conclusion produce a certain
result and it doesn't I think you should
acknowledge that and I think you ought
to change your views based on the
evidence and so it's a bottom line it in
a sentence America has changed so
dramatically in the 49 years that I've
been here that like why wouldn't my
politics change they've changed
completely on all kinds of different
issues and then I was once pretty
stridently pro-choice and for the death
penalty and now I have you know very
strong feelings in the opposite
direction I mean I support all kinds of
things that turned out to be wrong but
that's the point they turned out to be
wrong let's say you should reassess and
what drives me insane in living in
Washington for you know 35 years is
watching people make these grand
decisions with the best intentions by
the way I think most our policymakers
have good motives I do think that I know
them but they watch their policies fail
they don't acknowledge that they have
failed the extent they do they blame the
population for their failure and then
they repeat the mistake I have a bunch
of children
I'm never surprised when they make a bad
decision ever because people do they're
human I am too what I require is that
they acknowledge that they've made a
mistake that they say sorry and that
they try better based on what they've
learned from that mistake and that's
exactly what doesn't happen in
Washington that's why I'm mad so when it
comes to ideology so I actually am a
stronger believer in ideology than you
are one of the reasons being it seems to
me that the way that we determine
whether an appropriate metric for
success has been achieved is
ideologically based me know that we can
both look at the same policy and I can
say that its goal was achieved and if
you're using a different ideology you're
so it's not that you know what's here
what's your metric for success in on
particular issues so I guess I moved by
instinct increasingly again as I age
your your view changes I think mine has
the way you measure things changes I
increasingly distrust complexity in
worldview so I start with where I want
to end up what's the goal what kind of
society do you want to live in you want
to live in a place where the family is
basically unmolested where the human
conscience is totally unmolested where
you acknowledge you can control people's
behavior you can tell people you can do
that we all have to live together you
can't sleep in a crosswalk sorry it's
not allowed but what you never do is try
to control or mandate what people
believe that that is the kind of you
know that's a sphere that you would
never violate and so in the end you want
to live if you're in a democracy any
democracy you want to live in a country
or the middle class normal people you
know with hundred IQs making 80 grand a
year can lead you know productive
meaningful lives unbothered by the
people in power and they have the hope
at least that their kids can do slightly
better than they have that was kind of
the rule for a lot of that certainly the
post-war period in this country and it
no longer is
so my question always is not like what
party wins or you know is my economic
theory validated or not it's can we get
back to that or can get as close to that
as we possibly can and we're moving
farther away from it that's my
frustration so I think that there are a
couple issues that you mentioned there
and I might want to bifurcate them for
purposes of the discussion so issue
number one is sort of the free speech
issue people should be able to say what
they want people should be able to you
lead their families how they want to
lead them there were in complete
agreement
right and I think that you know the the
unity of the right is largely based on
agreement on this particular point the
foundational questions without which
none of the rest is possible right and
free expression would be one of course a
frame of conscience right and you talk a
lot in ship of fools particularly about
the threat to these sorts of ideas from
a left that is focused on a sort of
forced diversity and you've been labeled
racist by folks at media matters for
this of course because they label
everyone a racist I'm a Nazi according
to media matters because my yarmulke
apparently but your your viewpoint on
diversity is basically as I see it
expressed in the book that diversity is
a neutral it see it doesn't it's not
good or bad inherently it's not a value
description right and so where do you
see the conflict lying between right and
left on that particularly where I agree
with you is that you know while as I
noted I am distrustful of complex
ideologies I do think that you need to
start with certain things that you
believe are true and act on them if you
want to get to the police you deserve to
be so what I just noticed just as an
American and I'm not an intellectual I'm
a talk show host so this is a very
obvious thing that our national motto
has been redefined to its mirror image
so of course it was out of meaning one
and now it is diversity is our strength
so I think it's fair if you without
asking my consent replace the core
principle of our country it's fair for
me to ask if that principle is worth
organizing a country around so just ask
the obvious question is diversity our
strength and of course like so much they
say it's not only untrue it's the
opposite of what is true it is never
true that diversity is like I'm for all
kinds of diversity but they're not our
strengths in other words is it true in
your marriage the less you have in
common with your wife the stronger your
marriage is we don't speak the same
language that's why we love each other
is it true in your business we don't
know we're all doing it is it true in a
military you don't know it's insane
actually it's the opposite once again of
what is true what is observably true so
I just noted that and by the way at the
same time I noted it as I did you know
50 nights in the past 200 nights I made
the case explicitly against racism which
is you are not respond
for your immutable qualities you can't
control your height your hair color your
DNA which your parents did none of that
is your fault and you should not be
punished for it or rewarded for it that
is an argument against racism explicitly
and so for that I'm a racist it's like
can you understand I'm arguing against
all kinds of racism I think it's a
really dangerous way to see the world
and anyway whatever it is they don't
mean anything they say they throw at you
the very things that they are doing in
order to silence you and I just happen
for this brief window of my wife to have
the freedom to say what I think is true
and I'm going to it seems to me that
this is actually the major rift in
American politics and I want to get to
your economics in a second cuz I think
there we actually have some substantive
disagreement yeah but yeah there's a lot
of talk these days about political
realignment and I wonder if it's not
really political realignment that's
taking place but hunkering down of the
far left into the diversity politics
identity politics and then just the
backlash to that because it seems to me
that was the real dividing line between
Obama and Trump is not even on economics
where in some areas there's actually
some sort of populist agreement that's
but it's really on these sort of
cultural divisions where President Obama
was was basically saying you know we can
be divided into various ethnic groups
all of whom have been victimized by
America and then we can create a
coalition of the dispossessed to come
back in and sweep into power and the new
demographic shift will will basically
buoy our boat all the way to victory
from now until the end of time and then
the backlash for that was well wait a
second you know you guys don't get to do
identity politics when you've been
saying that identity politics is what's
wrong with America for generations
correctly so why are you doing that now
well it's a practical matter it just
doesn't work
I mean countries don't hang together by
accident particularly large diverse ones
they don't have a majority in any
category so there's no if you don't even
have a shared language or history or
culture you know why would you Cola you
know why would you remain united as a
country and the answer which I actually
believe in is that you could hang
together around a common idea a common
set of beliefs here's what we're all for
but our ruling class and I do think this
is the least responsible most reckless
thing they have done is they have not
only failed to come up with what that
set of common beliefs is they have
argued against the
that it should exist and so like the
what they're doing clearly is I mean
it's not complicated they're dividing in
order to rule of course what the British
did in India but that's the shortest
term think I mean that's like day trader
thing you do yeah yeah so what do you
think is are those common ideals you say
that you know there's certain things
that you think are just basic to being
American
what are those common ideals I guess I'd
start with the Bill of Rights I mean
that's not hard do you don't II mean
since it is a founding document it's the
foundational document and but I think
look you'll notice the book is long on
diagnostics and short on solutions
because that reflects Who I am and what
I do is not a policymaker at all I'm an
observer I'm not a deep systemic thinker
again I'm a talk-show host name so I'm
pretty good at telling you what I think
is wrong it's not as clear how you fix
it other than go back to the obvious
things like demand that everybody who
comes to this country for economic
opportunity for example or for the
safety of our rule of law also buy into
the things that makes all of us
Americans like it's not it's not
complicated really so yeah I will start
with the Bill of Rights like you have an
absolute right as defined in 1967 by the
Supreme Court but also by four centuries
of tradition here in this country which
we inherited from another culture across
the ocean to believe what you believe
unmolested period it's an absolute right
you can't violate my conscience and that
right is under assault not by a
political party but by in effect a
secular evangelical faith which were
calling progressive or liberal or
whatever it is not it's a species of
religion that seeks to convert by force
and that is deeply anguished and
concerned that other people disagree so
like I doubt you go home tonight and
fret at any length over the idea that
somewhere and Williamsburg Brooklyn
someone disagrees with you want to just
tell me not thinking about wait exactly
I'm not famous Frank and I can promise
you somewhere in Williamsburg right now
someone is lying in a studio apartment
fretting that in the you know the far
reaches of red-clay Alabama someone's
not fully on board with the bathroom
program
and they need to do something about it
so actually it's an asymmetrical contest
between one group that wants to affect
policy outcomes in the other group that
wants to convert by the sword so it's
the religious people versus the
political people and I don't even think
we acknowledge that most of the time so
one of the things that you do in the
book and I want to ask for clarification
on this because you've mentioned the
words elites a few times yeah and when I
talk about elites what I've really tried
to do is distinguish elites from
elitists because elites to me our folks
who very often you have elite in every
field you have a leap in the NBA because
they're the best basketball player right
you have elite economically many times
because they went to a good school and
because they have generated some sort of
service or good that a lot of people
want to buy into and then you have
elitists who are in my opinion the
people who are really the problem the
folks who think that they ought to be
able to cram down their values on
somebody else are you conflating elite
with elitist because obviously look
you're an elite right you're a guy who's
very wealthy you've done very well for
yourself that's the whole point of the
book is that and then I hope I one thing
I try never to do is pose as something
I'm not right now I'm not an accusation
it's not no no but I just want to be
extra clear I'm anali to remember Lawson
I mean we do also I grew up in La Jolla
and Georgetown I'm not here to give you
the view view from coal country I'm here
to give you the view from the world I
grew up in and have lived in always
which is the world of the people making
a disproportionate number of the key
decisions in our country economic
political cultural determine you know
like who makes the most money so I guess
the question was is that an economic
status or is that a mindset because no
no it's a practical reality every
society is hierarchical I'm not arguing
against that people are innately
hierarchical so we're dogs it's a mammal
thing okay so you're not gonna change
that there will always be people who are
making more decisions than other people
who are making more money than other
people they are the people at the top of
your society what has changed from
previous generations is not simply the
magnitude of the concentration of wealth
and power their life do you think is
like measurably that it is more
disproportionate than ever but that's
not really what's changed what's
actually changes the mindset of the
people in charge they no longer
acknowledge they're in charge and they
no longer acknowledge that they have a
responsibility to the people whose lives
they influence so the robber barons we
learn you know Carnegie and Rockefeller
and Phipps and all the people we learned
- hey
in ninth grade those people you know had
a lot of flaws and I do think the
concentrations of their wealth was a
threat that did justify what Teddy
Roosevelt did you know name breaking up
the trust was really important to allow
capitalism to continue but one thing I
would say in their defense is they knew
they were in charge they admitted it and
they understood that it came with
obligations because it always does if
you're a parent you know you're in
complete control of your children you
can do whatever you want to them you can
make more funny hands hats dance on one
foot you can make it speak it for
language you can do whatever you want
they're your kids you're God but with
those rights your rights as a parent
come obligations to take care of the
people over whom you have control and
that is what has been lost and so Travis
the teenage billionaire who ran ruber
founded it oversaw the second biggest
work force employee workforce in the
world and yet he didn't claim there was
employees he didn't pay their health
insurance he did one third of them lost
money working for him now you could say
well it's the free market of okay fine
but it doesn't absolve him of his core
responsible if you're creating a
hierarchy of responsibilities first is
to the people closest to you and that
would include your children your spouse
your employees and then to the world
they've inverted that so Travis was
always lecturing the rest of us about
police brutality or black lives matter
or a global warming or whatever what he
was doing was displacing his
responsibility from the real and the
tangible to the theoretical and
cost-free so I would get these notices
of my my uber app being like let's pause
for a moment to remember the victims a
police voucher but you know that's fine
but before you start lecturing me about
my moral inadequacies and about how you
care more than I do maybe you could pay
for the health insurance you're freaking
employees pal mr. teenage billionaire
guy like so this is actually part of a
much larger syndrome that grows out of
the meritocracy the SAT created sixty
years ago that has convinced the people
in charge that everything that and I
trust me this is the world I'm from this
convinced them that of course they're
richer and better educated and by the
way more attractive than the people in
the great middle of the country in the
medieval parts of the country
okay that's all true but they're
convinced that they're succeeding
because they're better they are better
their time should better person I'm a
better choices than you this is where I
think we come to the second half where
we disagree so I talked about
bifurcating sort of the conversation
into elite control of your life in terms
of family life and everything else with
the economic suggestion the meritocracy
itself is deeply flawed and that the
meritocracy can only survive if the
people on the top of the meritocracy
start to essentially give things away to
a certain extent so the the uber
suggestion that you make for example the
reason that oberoth operates with a
bunch of independent contractors is
obviously because it's less costly it's
because it's less costly that uber is
able to have an extraordinarily
profitable enterprise that allows them
to have all these independent
contractors in the first place if you
have employees then basically of a taxi
medallion company and that restrict
supply obviously that leads to increased
pricing which leads to more
competitiveness with the taxi companies
worse product for consumers so the
question is when it comes to you know
this idea that the meritocracy itself is
deeply flawed I've read I want to read
you a quote from your book because it
struck me because it's obviously a
really well-written book and and it
makes some arguments that struck me is
actually very much in sync with for
example some of the things that Bernie
Sanders says so the quote is this want
me to say because they are okay so
that's exactly when a second so here's
the quote prosperity is a relative
measure it doesn't matter how much
brightly colored plastic crap I can buy
from China if you can buy more you're
the rich one I'm poor by comparison
poverty doesn't cause instability envy
does so I actually agree with the last
couple of sentences that Envy causes
instability but my solution to that is
people should actually it's it's
actually against the 10 commandments
like you should stop worrying about what
your buddy has if your life is better I
couldn't agree more
despite all the talk about economic
stagnation in the United States since
1979 you can get a lot better stuff that
she colored plastic wrap is not just
junk from China I mean you're talking
about better cars better refrigerators
better air conditioning bigger houses in
many cases great I'm out with a benefit
for all but how's that worked I mean so
what's the suicide rate doing right now
well I think the suicides is elected
Donald Trump president right as if you
needed a clearer indicate
there is profound not just
dissatisfaction but unrest you would not
elect Donald Trump president unless you
were enraged and desperate and so we do
not take this seriously that's that's
the point so where do you draw the lines
then on government control so for
example there are many lines to look at
let me just say I'm not a secret
socialist every view of mine is
completely trimmed up for job and not
accusing you they I don't think you are
I just want to be clear about it yeah I
just think that policy makers never
should've vert their gaze from the goal
which is a stable Society stability is
underrated it's underrated because we've
always had it so it's almost like you
know you don't appreciate a friend until
he dies oh man I wish I'd you know told
him I loved him or whatever we've had
with a four-year exception almost
continuous social stability the strata
upon which we built our economy and our
civil society all of that was possible
because we had a stable society the
middle class that was the majority and
now we don't and so we're not thinking
clearly about what's going to happen
unless and until we regain that
stability and the core factor driving it
is expanding inequality not just the
fact that our ruling class is richer
than it's ever been including me but
that the rest of the country is going in
the other direction a life expectancy
for huge parts of the country is in
decline like that's the most Susu so I
guess I would just say the problem with
the meritocracy is not that the idea of
a meritocracy is bad I'm I'm completely
for it I'm from Southern California I
mean talk about a region predicated on
meritocracy nobody cares where you're
from you know to music what can you do
what's right that is a core belief of
mine I'm merely saying that if you have
an economy that suddenly makes labor
valueless physical labor valueless and
rewards dramatically I'm not going to
differentially dramatically cognitive
ability what you're really saying is we
have a class system based on IQ now
Charles Murray wrote a book on this 25
years ago that included a very
controversial race chapter which he
never should have included because it
obscured the core point of the book
which is what I just said right and then
you're coming apart which is basically
the book without the race
you ever shredded it it's like actually
the most brilliant thing I've read in
the past 20 years those two books
together explain what has happened we
have a ruling class that has almost
impenetrable actually you can't join
unless you have inequalities that are
the kind of price of membership I mean
we do have 7 million unfilled jobs in
the economy right now you do people are
moving less however than they have in
the past 30 years so the real question
is you mentioned the suicide rate it
seems to me that your explanation of a
lot of the social discontent in the
United States is economically based yes
and for me I think that a lot of that
social discontent is less economically
based and spiritually based because we
are more wrong I'm doubtful actually and
the reason that I'm doubtful is because
we are as a society more prosperous than
any society in the history of humanity
including the people at the lower end of
the spectrum and that's not to say that
there aren't people suffering but
compared by comparison to any other time
in human history it's not close no but
I'm not making that argument though so
this is the canvas is the Heritage
Foundation argument like you're worried
about the poor they you know they have
three color TVs I get it and I believe
that for a long time and I'm for
whatever I don't right you're right
that's great and I'm grateful that no
one is starving and has never starved
really in the last hundred years here
including during the Depression but
that's missing the point what you want
is a society that is cohesive where
everyone feels part of the same thing
you don't want the people who are making
the huge majority of important decisions
to be completely cut off from everyone
else for a bunch of reasons one it will
engender resentment inevitably as it has
and there are people who feel a
resentment since they still have the
vote their Labor's worth nothing okay
that's where labor unions have collapsed
the value of Labor has declined over the
past ten years dramatically but they
still do franchise they still have
political power and what are they gonna
do with that power they're going to
punish you but is it isn't the way to
appeal ISM and that Trump is the
beginning of that is it but isn't the
way that at least the founders thought
of this that the way to prevent the
elites you know an elite class from
controlling other people's lives is to
restrict the inherent power of
government to control everybody's life
when you suggested before that that the
goal of the society should be stability
every
stable society there are lots of
different I mean you say this in the
book there are lots of different types
of stable society there I mean there are
monarchies that are stable societies
there are their communist regimes that
are stable right exactly their dicta
their dictatorships that are incredibly
North Korea is a very stable Society
that's right so is the goal of our
society stability primarily or freedom
and when's the to come in conflict
because they often do and that's that's
an incisive question and you're exactly
right and I would say to narrow the goal
down to a single thing as I did is
probably stupid stability makes a lot of
other things that you want possible but
I would say within the American context
what you want is a country where the
average person again with an IQ of a
hundred and you know an income of 90
grand a year and three kids can sort of
live the life that people lived under
those circumstances in 1950 like you
want and they and the average person to
feel like he's vested in the society
that he can have a stable family without
you know by the way we just say the
economic impetus behind family
destruction is totally underappreciated
by conservatives so they looked at the
landscape of inner-city America for 50
years and they're like nope you know
family formations bought like the
overall majority of kids grow up without
a father that's a cultural problem okay
yeah it is called surprise that's one
way to describe it but what's its route
why did it happen well look at rural
America now where you're seeing the
incidence of child was of a
fatherlessness like spike yeah it's it's
unknown in my neighbor I live in a rich
neighborhood I'm sure you did everyone's
married okay there's no divorce where I
live in rural America divorce among
white people is now the rule out of
wedlock births and a lot of zip codes
are the majority it's not why did that
happen because the men make less than
the women nobody wants then there's so
much social science on this nobody wants
to say it out loud because you're
violating some unspoken rule of like
unhappy feminism or something I don't
care it's true
study after longitudinal study has shown
that when men make less women don't want
to marry them now maybe they should ask
asked I have three daughters ask them
and they're not ideological at all and
they're totally open-minded they're
young people would you want to marry a
man who makes less than you what no do
you think that's because of structural
changes in the America
American economy or the counter-argument
which would be the welfare state which
is when you start to see Oh first it of
course plays a huge role in this but I'm
talking employed people so in when
manufacturing dies what's left will in a
lot of parts of the country huge swaths
of rural America you have two main
employers the schools and hospitals
those are the full-time year-round
employers and those are traditionally
female job not exclusive right there are
many exceptions to all of this and there
are plenty of women who are happy to
marry a man who makes less than they do
but I'm saying across large populations
that is true and it's been shown to be
true so when male wages decline below
those of females marriage formation
declines along with it but childbirth
does not right in other words they're
sort of hardwired to impregnate okay
that continues so what the net effect is
you have no families and more kids
especially boys growing up in fatherless
homes which all but guarantees that you
repeat the process only you have the
disintegration of the family because of
an economic factor there are other
factors and I of course so I are you
coming for a redistribution into these
areas I mean because it seems like for
whatever it takes to stop this right so
this is where I was asking about the
Bernie Sanders crossover where do you
see the Bernie Sanders I have no gram
going to Sanders is a buffoon okay I
know you know that we totally insincere
but I'm saying conservatives go on and
have for generations about how important
the family they don't mean it at all
I live in DC where the entire concern of
nonprofit infrastructure lives okay and
I know what their priorities are and
they're lowering marginal tax rates
which I'm for by the way as someone who
pays the majority of his income in taxes
a kind of course I'm for that but the
goal if the goal is preserving the
family as the core building block of any
successful society and it's got to be
that goal because it has all kinds of
effects that we want
it's just inherently good it's I don't
even to explain it but I could but the
point is if that's the goal what are you
doing about it if you wake up one
morning you find yourself in a society
where 23 year olds with four-year
college degrees and like initiative who
aren't smoking weed every day if they
can't make enough to buy a car much less
a home much less get married much less
have children then why should you
be surprised when half of them say they
prefer socialism well that should not be
surprised I agree to certain extent I
think that the the the question is when
the pedal hits the metal leg you talk in
the in book about technology and how its
shifting and taking away jobs from folks
then you make specific reference to
truck driving and the fact that they're
going these automated cars on the roads
so would you Tucker Carlson be in favor
of restrictions on the ability of
trucking companies to use this sort of
technology specifically to you know sort
of artificially maintain the number of
jobs that are available in the trucking
energy joking
in a second in a second in other words
if I were president when I say the d-o-t
department ran spur tation we're not
letting driverless trucks on the road
period why really simple driving for a
living is the single most common job for
high school educated men in this country
in all 50 states okay that's the same
group whose wages have gone down by 11
percent over the past 30 years the
social cost of limiting their jobs in a
10 year span five year span thirty year
span is so high that it's not
sustainable so the greater good is
protecting your citizens from look
capitalism is the best economic system I
can think of I think that anyone's ever
thought of but that doesn't mean that
it's a religion and everything about it
is good but there's no nice and creative
capitalism that I have to buy into what
I care about is living in a country
where you know decent people can live
happy lives actually and so no I would
say I mean no are you joking and I maybe
it would make up some pretext for public
consumption like oh they're dangerous
the technology's not quite finessed no
no but the truth would be I don't want
to put 10 million men out of work with
it because you're gonna have 10 million
dead families and the cascading effect
from that will wreck your country so I'm
gonna ask about the limiting principle
there in just a second but first let's
talk about talk space so if you're
feeling a little bit nervous because of
this conversation because you're one of
these people in an industry that's being
assaulted by technology or if you're
just a person who is having trouble at
home maybe you need to go to talk space
it's the online therapy company that
lets you message a licensed therapist
from anywhere at any time all you need
is a computer with internet connection
or the talk space mobile app that means
you can improve your mental health even
if you had trouble making time for it
the past I'm a big advocate by the way
of folks talking to somebody if you need
to do so I think it's one of the
stupidest stigmas in American life that
you're supposed to sit there and try and
grit your teeth and make your way
through life without any help at all
it's idiotic
if you can't imagine fitting anything
else in your life with talk space
therapy is as easy as sending your
therapist a message get something off
your chest whenever you need to talk
about everyday challenges at work or at
home you can chat about life there no
extra commutes no leaving the office and
no judgment it's a therapy
I remember the therapy isn't just about
venting your innermost thoughts it's
about practical everyday strategies for
stress management living a happier life
having a therapist simply provides you a
designated person for you to talk to
somebody trained to listen and help you
make positive changes the talk space
platform has over 2,000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing life challenges we all face
to match with the perfect therapist for
a fraction the price of traditional
therapy go to talk space.com slash
Schapiro use that promo code Shapiro you
have 45 bucks off your first month and
show your support for this show that's
Shapiro talk space.com slash apparel you
get that special deal so back to the the
technology question so it's it's
fascinating to me that you're so willing
to restrict technology in this
particular area not because it's not a
justifiable Powell it's not not willing
eager to it wills so do that what's the
limiting principle because obviously
jobs are lost in industries through
creative destruction and have been for
the entire time the free market has
existed or I mean wheelwrights lost
their jobs when when the automobile was
created what's to prevent this principle
you're speaking up from just becoming
Luddite ISM that technology's destroying
jobs I don't think very technology
insane I mean there were massive costs
to the Industrial Revolution having
babies here found of capitalism in
development and we will have all the
core stuff we have right I mean me yeah
I'm for capitalism I'm for machines
right you know they they've all but
guarantee I'll live way longer than my
great-grandparents I get it in for
machines okay I'm just saying that there
was a cost half the world was enslaved
for 70 years under Bolshevism because
those countries didn't manage I would
argue the transition from an agrarian
economy into an industrial one that's
what that was okay
so we're on the cusp of a completely
transformative revolution as or more
transformative as the Industrial
Revolution and no one is trying to take
control of it at all or figure out how
to channel these forces into an
outcome that we want to live with
realistically and because they're not
you're going to see reactions and you're
already seeing reactions against this
stuff that are flat-out extreme so the
model again is Teddy Roosevelt who was a
capitalist a patriot a man of deep faith
he was not anti-business and yet he
restrained American business as he broke
them up and was hated for doing it in
the service of a higher goal which was a
stable happy country where the
traditions could be preserved if he
didn't do that you know there's there's
no telling like what would have happened
to the the wobbly or the IWW or whatever
we could have gone in a totally
different direction
I mean so I will admit I'm not as heady
Roosevelt fan and I would have opposed
the trust-busting but when it comes to
the when it comes to the sort of
politics we're talking about
I guess my major question is is it a
contributing factor to societal unrest
to tell people that politics is to blame
for the problem are we are we edging on
political messianism the idea that if we
just change a couple of policies here or
there us and we'll be able to fix
everything when the reality is that as
you talked about a little bit in the
book what we may be suffering from is in
actual spiritual malaise and maybe
economics has something to do with it I
would argue that it has a lot more to do
with the generalized move away from
social fabric driven by all of the
references to existing churches and we
and all of these things in that if we're
going to if we are going to maintain
both freedom and stability
you know the John Adams formulation was
that this Constitution was only built
for a moral and virtuous people wasn't
built for any other not it there are two
ways to actually tackle that one is to
say we are no longer moral and no longer
virtuous so we have to change the
freedom and the other is to say well if
we want to maintain the freedom we have
to become moral and virtuous again and I
wonder if we as public figures we're in
the same business more or less where we
ought to be putting our focus should we
be putting our focus on justifying
people's fears about the economy and
suggesting the political Messiah is
around the corner or should we be saying
to people listen the industry in your
town may be dying and as a temporary
stopgap perhaps we can stop technology
from advancing perhaps we can stop trade
from eating your job or should be saying
to people listen
America was built by folks who crossed
mountains to go to the middle of nowhere
in pure risk and
you are guaranteed nothing in the United
States but the adventure of your life
there are seven million unfilled jobs
maybe we need to actually move maybe you
need to go to North Dakotan get a
fraction right yeah
leave yeah leave your parents graves in
the town you grew up in to move to some
solicit E and become a cog in some I
think well that's I mean the biblical
man's a leave the land that you've known
and adventure I don't know it's it's a
mixture of both and I and I would to
answer your initial question anyone who
argues that any of this is going to be
fixed by a person or a bill that makes
its way through Congress or new Supreme
Court justice is lying to you
that's a grotesque and dishonest
oversimplification of this short that
politicians and by the way talk show
hosts specialize in and so the to the
extent I played a role in lying about
that I'm sorry I never want to be that
guy I always want to acknowledge how
complex and multifaceted all of these
problems are because they are I'm merely
making a couple of very obvious
observation that there are downsides
cities are not servants of our economic
system we are not here to serve as
shareholders we're human beings and our
concerns are real now they must be
balanced against the concerns of
shareholders and lots of other concerns
but to say that you know if it's more
efficient to have you move to some
crappy suburb to serve some douchey
company because that's what you know is
best to increase value it's like it's
okay for me to stand up and say you know
there are other concerns here actually
and there's a social cost to doing that
anyway this all we used to be a fee
these things were actually debated
during the Industrial Revolution the
Luddites are used for propaganda
purposes to make the other side seem
ludicrous you're literally smashing
machines you're a dummy
you're an animal you don't mean but
actually the concern is totally real if
you spend I don't know just like roughly
five thousand years in one kind of
economy that changes incrementally over
time but basically living from what you
grow living with your family and working
a hundred yards away for thousands of
years and then in the space of I don't
know a hundred years after the steam
engine is invented everything is
completely different
that's a lot it doesn't mean that you
should stop it or smash the machines
with a hammer but it means you should be
thoughtful in the way you channel these
awesome forces these awesome economic
forces you are not a servant to them
they are tools that thoughtful people
use to increase the goodness of their
society so I guess I'm just struggling
like if I would ever talk to liberals or
conservatives market fundamentalists in
Washington like well we can't stop this
is technology it's adorable look we have
really no role in it other than to try
to benefit from it it's like really
you're talking about machines are they
really in charge no we're in charge
we're human beings with freewill God
created us to make these decisions no
but there is that there is a balance
obviously between increasing prosperity
across all of humankind which has really
been the result of free-market
capitalism
over the past 40 years and
redistribution of the benefits because
the benefits obviously fall upon people
deeply I'm not for taking stuff from
people I don't want my stuff to be taken
from me our regulations do that
effectively and president Trump has been
very anti regulatory because in a broad
sense maybe I guess I mean I know that
that's a talking point I'm not except I
mean yeah a lot of regulations are
unbelievably stupid and they benefit you
know certain categories of rennes seeker
at the expense of everyone else like I'm
very aware I live among it I know and a
lot of this is totally corrupt and
counterproductive okay for sure on the
other hand you we have an obligation to
think deeply about what's best for
normal people that's all I'm saying
that's that's it that's all I'm saying
and we are not powerless in the face of
these forces and if we decide that we
are powerless in the face of them we're
all just along for the ride
we're not the authors of history we're
merely just flotsam floating atop it
it's like whoa that's a totally
different way of thinking about it
that's really bad and as we go through
these changes the people benefiting most
to whom much is given much is expected
they should feel an obligation to those
beneath them in the way you feel care
that's it and then certainly I feel I
mean you know they just feel guilt as my
charity exists but exactly they should
you know the we underestimate to your
point and I think we're basically an
agreement almost everything especially
on this that the that your moral code
determines how you behave and I
you live and so the robber barons were
deeply fraught and guilty in some ways
about their success because they were
like guilty wasps they're Protestants
like I get it do you don't mean like
they're my people so I know exactly what
they used to think which was you know I
not everything I've achieved is the
result of choices that I made
they were Calvinists on some level like
they understood that there are other
thing Providence grace luck whatever you
want to call it that determined the
outcome so like the people now in charge
your average private equity guy and I
know a million of them in like them okay
but they believe that they're rich
because they're better because they made
good choices and you're not because you
didn't okay that's true in some sense a
choices do matter for sure I quit
drinking so I could like be more
successful it worked okay but how does
that explain the girl in your fourth
grade class who died of leukemia
did she make bad choices was it her
fault really if she just like what no a
lot of this is random I have the job I
have because of chance and when I start
telling myself I have the job I have
because I'm a genius that's when I my
soul corrodes actually and I become a
bad person so like we shouldn't allow
people to lie about the way life really
is that's all that's all I'm saying so
let's talk a little bit about another
area where you shifted and I think most
of America has shifted I think the year
shift has reflected a huge majority of
Americans and that is in a more
realistic ocean astir action on foreign
policies and the 90s you worked with
Bill Kristol obviously who's very
interventionist very doggish and you
have an entire chapter and ship of fools
devoted basically action that's a max
boot and book myself yeah and you know
what are your when do you think that
American intervention is appropriate
when it serves American interests
unambiguously and by the way speaking of
complicated I mean this stuff is
complicated yeah one thing that is
unknowable is the outcome you can only
guess at its outlines and often you're
wrong but you need to approach all of
these questions with deep humility
understanding that you know you think
that X will produce Y but it could
produce K like you don't really know if
you do that it doesn't mean you won't
make mistakes of course you will but
she'll make fewer mistakes less profound
mistakes hubris guarantees disaster
every single time you know it in every
context I mean its shafted David it will
shaft you yeah when you start thinking
that you're God you know you were gonna
fall from great heights and so the
problem is not these are very human
problems and they're long-standing
problems there are eternal problems but
when you have an entire city full of
policymakers who don't acknowledge these
problems that's when you want look I
supported the war in Iraq it made sense
to me sort of and I'm certainly willing
to go on faith and then I went to Iraq
and I was like wait
very soon after actually in the winter
of 2003 when I was like this is not at
all what I thought and we don't actually
have control of this country we're not
good colonialists because we're not
willing to admit we have an empire the
British were very effective and they
could absorb losses like they're lost in
Afghanistan because they were honest
about what they were doing was a
colonial power that existed for the
benefit primarily of Great Britain also
for the edification of the peoples over
whom they ruled like they had that it
was a component to that was a Christian
component an evangelical component to
British colonialism but basically it was
were acting in the interests of
civilization which we run we are totally
unwilling as a ruling class is more
broadly unwilling to admit were in
charge so we're not gonna ever be good
at it so your choices are do you
continue being bad at it or do you stop
doing it to what extent do you think
morality plays a role in foreign policy
if any is it is it they have again this
is I guess it's back to our basic you
must a heart of our foreign policy and
the moral question is what's good for
the people in our charge right so this
is so again that goes back to the
metrics of success so right the so is
the metric of success for let's let's
take an obvious example where you know
opinion is pretty fraud so take the
intervention in Syria right so I am NOT
Pro intervention in Syria I know you're
not Pro intervention in Syria by the
same token you look at the human carnage
that has taken place in Syria what's in
America's interests there do are we
judging that in terms of dollars and
cents are we touching that in terms of
what we would have to sacrifice in order
to stop the carnage are we justifying
that in terms of immigration as you say
it's very complex for again Syria is
maybe more complex than in certain other
situations but frankly let's - let me
take a different example so world war
two it's
when we look at World War 2 pretty much
all Americans agree we should have been
involved we were attacks by Japan
Germany declared war on us who have no
choice when you look in retrospect at
how we justify our involvement in World
War two most Americans have asked why we
were involved in World War two would
probably not say Pearl Harbor it would
point to ending the Holocaust and
defeating Hitler as a moral matter that
these are these are these were evil
regimes that needed to be defeated right
when is humanitarian intervention
justified not based on dollars and cents
or based purely on self-defense concerns
if at all you mean quite apart from
self-defense concerns when just offering
something something terrible is
happening somewhere in the working lives
I mean you know you have to weigh that's
a that's a Christian impulse Jewish
impulse it's a it's a decent impulse I
guess is what I'm saying to want to help
people I think that's right and we have
a robust NGO sector that makes its
business doing that - great
counterproductive effect exactly right
um but yeah life expectancy in
post-colonial Africa has gone down so
how's that working for you but anyway um
so I understand that impulse and I
admire it and I think this is the bet
not only the most prosperous but the
best country in human history so like I
get it I get it but you balance those
impulses against what's actually
achievable and always and everywhere the
threat that you will unintentionally
make things worse which is a very real
present threat always Americans have no
appreciation of that at all they one
thing that does bug me about my own
people is they don't have much
imagination for how things could be
worse so you're always hearing Americans
say hey how could it be worse okay
travel a little bit okay and you will
see that almost always it can be worse
so will you make it worse by trying to
make it better that's a real question
never concern it but but more broadly I
mean with this what is the situational
what if life is situational but the main
theme is that your foreign policy exists
for the behalf of your own country to
make your country stronger better safer
more insulated happier right richer
that's the point of it and if there's an
ancillary benefit of helping other
people I'm you know of course I'm
totally for that okay so
let's talk a little bit about the kind
of distinctions when it comes to the
philosophy of intervention because we've
talked about morality has to be a
component I agree
we've talked about the need to back
American interest which is obviously
first and foremost with which I also
agree to take the max boot for devil's
advocate purposes take the max boot bill
kristol position for a moment their
argument on the war on terror or
intervention ISM is that as you say
there are counterfactuals that we can't
actually assume so let's say that we
don't intervene in Afghanistan after
9/11 or we go in with a pinprick strike
or something or let's say that we don't
go into Iraq and let's say that two
years later there's another 9/11 style
attack we would never know that because
it never happened there's been a
decrease in the number of least mass
attacks in the United States over time
so their argument would be this is where
I was getting at with the metrics
question at the beginning by your
metrics the war in Iraq is a disaster
than war in Afghanistan has turned out
to be basically a disaster by their
metrics these are both been successes to
the extent that it has prevented
casualties on American soil assuming
there would have been more casualties on
American soil and one of the problems
with trying to you know assess these
issues you know in a looking forward
fashion know right exactly if you talk
in the book about American intervention
with regard to the Mujahideen in in
Afghanistan under Reagan and you point
out that this was a instrumental factor
in the fall of the Soviet Union yes but
should we have armed those people
considering that they would go on to get
it in the what these are judgment calls
made under pressure at the time under
public scrutiny often they're hard
decisions to make I think heaven don't
have to make them so I have deep empathy
for people who make the wrong decision
what I have contempt for is people who
won't acknowledge having made the wrong
decision and so there are many things
that we can't know hypotheticals you
know are by definition unknowable but I
think any fair person assessing the
aftermath of the Iraq war would have to
say deposing Saddam empowered Iran this
was his main regional rival okay
obviously and if you believe that Iran
is the single greatest threat to the
West and I don't believe that but many
people do everyone I know does all
people of good faith then you can't say
yuck war by that
standard that one measure which seems to
be at the center of people's foreign
policy understanding right now was a
good idea
you just can't so look I get it there
are a lot of things we didn't expect
though I think we should have
anticipated that take out someone's
chief rival you empower him by
definition but whatever we didn't but
what I can't stand was actually grates
on me he is the self-righteousness with
which they proceed forward as if that
never happened so it's like really if
you're not for this intervention or that
intervention you just don't have a heart
use don't care he's not a good person
well whoa you know these are decisions
are big decisions that we can make
without reference to my personal moral
values or yours let me just try to do
the best thing for the country but you
should at least acknowledge you the guy
who's telling me that we need to go to
war with Iran now that the decision that
you helped make created the problem that
you now tell me we need to solve you
should least admit that or else you're a
liar which they are okay so I do have
one final question before I want to ask
you about President Trump and now he's
done so far if you want to hear the
answer to that final question however
you do have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe go to daily wire
comm click subscribe give us money and
you can hear the end of our conversation
there well Tucker it's just great to
have you here I'm so glad you can make
it out to the west coast and this book
ship it fools you should definitely
check it out I'm sure you already have a
copy but if you do read it and if you
don't go by it and then read it because
it'll give you a great window into the
rasaan of American politics right now
thanks so much really
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate producer
Mathis Glover edited by Alex Singaram
audio is mixed by Dylan case Heron
makeup is by Jess wah alvera and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]